the team here at ABS Transport are used
to moving heavy cargo but it's rarely
been so urgent so personal owner Charon
is Turkish and lost her cousin in the
earthquake they had hoped to get enough
donations to take over a van instead
they're taking seven large lorries can I
just stress that none of this was old
stuff it wasn't people's cupboard
leftovers people went out and bought
nappies people went out and bought
blankets duvets pillows 70 of the cargo
that we have sent out on this truck has
been sorted and
um most of it was new
an appeal by UK Charities through the
disaster and emergency committee has so
far raised more than 60 million pounds
fears are growing about a second
catastrophe survivors have Little
Shelter as temperatures plunge overnight
to minus five we will prioritize over
the next six months of course the
emergency phase that's ensuring that
people can survive survive the winter
and have the basics the food a clean
water uh somewhere to live and the
medical assistance and then beyond that
possibly for at least another two years
to try to help people get back on their
feet the crisis in Syria is being
compounded by the Civil War nearly five
and a half million people are thought to
be homeless one of the most vulnerable
areas is the last rebel-held province of
idlib in the northwest of the country
but there is currently only one
officially permitted crossing point and
that was damaged in the earthquake
the UN Security Council will discuss
opening up more routes so far Russia and
China have used their veto to back the
Syrian government's claim that this
would violate its sovereignty the UN Aid
Chief met the Region's volunteer civil
defense organization the white helmets
he apologized for shortcomings in
supplying help it's an open and shut
case on humanitarian terms why we need
those extra Crossing points now to save
lives and to provide some sort of
assistance to the people as they come
into the post rescue phase the UK
International Development Aid budget is
around 11 billion pounds of which the
government is responsible for
Distributing about 7 billion but in 2022
more than half those funds were spent
domestically the budget is is is under
very considerable stress but we are
still spending a great deal of money
there not far short of 200 million
pounds so we're doing what we can and we
are having a big effect on the ground
and it is partly because of the work we
do through International ngos as well as
through the United Nations that we know
what's happening on the ground there and
we are therefore able to ensure that
British help really gets through to
those who need it
donations from the British public have
already exceeded the amount raised in
other recent natural disasters despite
the cost of living crisis but the scale
of this catastrophe is so great that far
more will be needed from individuals and
governments to rebuild lives and cities
Thomas More Sky News